I was setting up the bridal party...
...to take the bridal party photographs like I do at every wedding,...
...and so I took a few shots of that, and then I said,...
"Okay, now I need the bride and groom to kiss."
So when I said that, well naturally, she thought I was referring to her...
...because she thought she was the bride.
And so, naturally she just leaned in for a kiss and kissed that ring bearer.
Guess what? When mom and Ike kissed, Ikey and I kissed.
I was trying to get Ikey to kiss me.
I said, "Okay, let's try that again. One more time, bride and groom kiss."
And she really went for it that time and it was hilarious.
I strive to capture the moment of the day,...
...so for me to be able to capture that moment,...
...that's a moment that the families can look back on for years to come...
...and laugh and relive it over again.
He was the best ring bearer ever.
And he thought I was the best flower girl ever.
We're best friends.